alain ducasse bonjour bonjour merci nous
rejoindre pour nous accorder un peu de
votre précieux temps dans les jardins du
château de versailles pour un événement
extraordinaire qui va avoir lieu donc
tout à l'heure à savoir la cueillette de
la bonnotte
on en dira plus après moi je voudrais
bien sûr tout le monde vous connaît
jama juste te dire éventuellement
l'essentiel à savoir que vous êtes un
petit garçon des landes
vous avez grandi en chalosse là vous
nous dites dans vos interviews vous avez
appris le vrai produit le bon goût je ne
vois là le goût originel merci de me le
goût originel d'une salade de radis d'un
petit poids d'une pomme nouvelle d'un
oignon nouveau la ciboulette en fleur
qui pousse quand on utilise aussi bien
la fleur que la tige
on va s'attacher à consommer ce que le
jardin nous donne et ma grand-mère pour
déjeuner à 11h30 le disais qu'est ce
qu'on va manger à midi on allait au
jardin donc trouver ce qu'il y avait à
manger actions des saisons l'hiver y
avait toujours des racines mais en tout
cas là la période bénie pour les jardins
pour les jardiniers et pour les
cuisiniers c'est le printemps l'été et
le début de l'automne après c'est un peu
plus difficile mais nous j'aime beaucoup
les racines donc j'aime aussi beaucoup
la cuisine d
beaucoup plus terrienne que nous donnent
les racines des fruits divers moi j'aime
beaucoup les pois j'aime beaucoup les
les radis noir les navets les poireaux
j'aime beaucoup les cards
je suis content tout le temps nourri
comme ça voilà donc quand vous dites le
goût original ça veut dire les vrais
goûts j'aimerais dire qu'une salle adam
jensen y blanc et quand on goûte seul et
blanc et quand on goûte la gn goûter
j'ai retrouvé ce goût originel qui est
resté gravé dans ma mémoire qui est dans
mon adn qui est resté dans mon disque
dur gravé dans mon disque dur et
finalement ça composent l'adn est
partout c'est ma mesure étalon du goût
partout jouets j'ai toujours en référant
quand j'ai goûté un boulet au bout du
monde n'est jamais aussi bon que le
poulet ma ferme
bien sûr qu'il ya d'autres tous les
aujourd'hui quand d'autres talents mais
mon goût originel mon adn il a été
construit avec les goûts que j'ai
découvert en force et la forme est là
elle a fait un peu il y avait des
canadiens ont déjà dépêché deux bouts
jong il finalement on allait au village
je parle une fois par semaine pour aller
acheter khider ont peu d'huile un peu de
sel
number c'était le voisin qui le faisait
parce qu'on lui donne et donnez-nous on
dirait juste quelques produits
d'épicerie hockey où elle vivra nos
essais la de là qu'est venue votre goût
de la cuisine vous êtes dis petit je
veux être chef
ma grand mère cuisinait bien j'ai des
souvenirs d'odeurs j'ai des souvenirs
des goûts des produits du jardin mais
des souvenirs d'odeurs de la cuisine et
je pense c'est encore pour ça que je dis
et j'essaie de faire une cuisine qui a
une odeur quand elle est chaude je veux
que je veux connaît le plaisir de sentir
le plat avant le visuel et avant le goût
donc oui c'est payer l'essence cinéma
bien sûr d'accord donc là vous vous êtes
dit quand je serai grand je serai sans
savoir et puis finalement oui n'est pas
supporter que je fasse à la cuisine
anglaise mais les goûter mais quand même
je finis à l'école hôtelière de bordeaux
finit très rapidement d'ailleurs puisque
comme ça va passer comme ça va passer
les claqué la porte avant le diplôme
passé on en apprend un peu de choses on
met beaucoup de temps pour apprendre
vite
c est peut-être déjà un bagage qui
visait que maintenant partout j'avais
envie d'apprendre plus vite maintenant
donc je suis je me suis échappé je suis
comment ces jeux michel guérard pas
l'irlande et à soustons en face de
l'apce a préféré langlade qui était
ryser de campagne de françois mitterrand
se maintient après vous êtes descendus
en provence je vais d'argent vous avez
découvert nouvelle cuisine j'ai été
adopté par le goût des couleurs les
saveurs les odeurs de méditerranée voilà
que vous connaissiez pas hésiter non les
poissons de méditerranée ils ont un goût
unique les gameiro dingle de jeannie
longo unique les tomates aussi un goût
unique vous savez ces fruits d'amélie
tehran et ils ne sont jamais meilleurs
cowboys la méditerranée donc c'est une
distinction
de ce groupe italien qui que j'ai pour
passion comme deuxième passion et puis
finalement la méditerranée made up tv
creuser donc voilà je pense préférant
vivre et de livres sur la méditerranée
ça me passionne et finalement c'est ma
peau ma région d'adoption on améliore et
donc vous avez aujourd'hui un premier
restaurant le louis 15 à monte carlo
mais toile et on sait pourquoi ce nom le
goût 15 parce que c'était le salon que
j'ai choisi à l'époque de prince rainier
me dit choisissez une des salles dans la
société des bains de mer qui avait
décidé à m'engager comme chef et il y a
un très joli salon disponible dans un
bon endroit qui est
le côté droit de l'entrée de l'hôtel de
paris finalement ce salon s'appelle
depuis 1864 le 8 15
on décide de l'appeler 8,15 alain
ducasse départ est annoncé
c'est une trace est historique et
d'ailleurs ce lieu destiné en fait un
restaurant est un lieu unique magnifique
c'est certainement la coquille le
plafond les murs les qualités d'onyx
l'onyx sont des pc pierre qui monte du
sol au plafond un peu dans l'esprit de
dans l'esprit versailles et oui
d'excellence c'est une coquille c'est
une coquille extraordinaire et là je
m'occupe pas de la copie elle est très
belle il ya la lecture au mur pour le
client qui arrivent et moi je m'occupe
de lui donner le nourriture celle que
j'aime c'est elle qui m'a adopté c'est
un concentré d'une cuisine à la fois
marine et paysannes de la rivière à la
riviera française à riviera italienne et
donc c'est ma combinaison
c'est une cuisine
qui exprime couleurs saveurs et odeurs
la méditerranée je m'occupe un peu de ce
qu'il ya autour
c'est une copie extradé vient c'est
certainement le restaurant commercial le
plus extraordinaire du extraordinaire du
monde parce qu'il est historique d'accor
alors on va remonter un peu plus au nord
à savoir ici à versailles
e qu'est ce que vous faites ici
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe
racontez-moi d'où vient il ya quelques
petites années on a décidé de devenir
j'avais une idée en tête c'est en
devenant mécènes et château de
versailles un jour de pouvoir remettre
en exploitation le potager de la reine
qui n'avait pas été très sollicité
depuis qu'un décennies et voir quelques
siècles dont nous remettre en culture et
de faire en sorte que la nature
suffisent pas de produits de traitement
il pleut ça permet aux légumes de
pousser il fait un peu plus chaud mais
il pousse même bien même tout cas ont
fait au minimum et du coup on a des
légumes assez extraordinaire il somme à
vol d'oiseau tout près du restaurant
dont les comédiens que ses protégés du
restaurant mais c'est le potager le
reste l'activité
j'entends finalement il ya un lien qui
s'est créé entre alain baraton le le
garçon mehdi en charge de cultiver les
légumes pour le lire entre romain mon
chef voilà dans tout ça et une osmose
parfaite et on va améliorer tous les
jours l'excellence des légumes en
préserver l'amertume pour ceux qui sont
amers d'acidité la juste malgré leur
goût original
vins nature va faire ce qu'elle doit
faire et alors concrètement déjà ça fait
combien de temps que ses excès mis en
place cette collaboration va commencer
au printemps dernier mais bon le
faillirent même et c'est le premier
printemps qui nous donne deux oui ça y
est on y est vive entièrement sur la
production est justement des potagers de
la production on va parler plus
précisément d'une petite pomme de terre
qui s'appelle la benâte de noirmoutier
ouais il ce qui va très très bien ici
mais très bon moi c'est pas tellement ça
n'altère et xtreme nommé la terre il
c'est exceptionnel
il n'y a pas de hasard si le roi avait
décidé de différer le potager de la
reine c'est que certainement
c'est dans ce carré de jardin que la
terre devait être la meilleure il n'y a
pas de hasard n'ont finalement pour le
territoire dire elle est très bonne
naturellement mais en plus la terre
permet de la faire très bonne donc on va
on va dégoûter tout à l'heure
donc en fait voilà c'est une grande
première pour l accueillir aujourd'hui
j'ai une passion pour la première de la
moitié depuis longtemps donc c'est pas
nouveau
ouï dire tiens on va à la plante et
parce que cette terre est très bonne
mais lilou 10 la terre est
extraordinaire mais c'est vrai qu'elle
nous en aiguille extraordinaire c'est
bien calé elle n'est pas sûre solliciter
les animaux en dessous pour leur travail
il n'y a pas de pesticides n'y a pas de
traitement il n'ya pas dormir
lapin non il n'ya pas j'en ai pas vus
pourtant les feuilles sont bonnes mais
oui c'est un petit stand et dites moi
donc concrètement comment ça se passe
vous avez des jardiniers du site vous
téléphone
il amène ce ski à mehdi nous amène ce
qui est à juste maturité ni trop ni trop
peu
mika dakar autour des bassins et des sit
in y avait bien sûr il nous casse est
prêt il vous amène et nous on traite
on cuisine on assaisonne en piles les
feuilles on va extraire l'amertume de la
racine dit voilà on va s'attacher à
préserver tous les goût originel d'une
plante pour la proposer aux clients
d'ailleurs en cela les clients ils sont
appelés à redécouvrir que l'endive est
amer aujourd'hui elle a poussé hors sol
elle a été greffée
mais plus que croquante l'on dit venez
c'est même plus que la poussée un
journal terre alors que quand c'est une
endive le planteur une belle à une belle
racines on va s'attacher à préserver à
prélever de s'être assis de l'amertume
que j'adore j'adore l'amertume d'acidité
sont pas des goûts communs mais ce sont
des gouffres ses dégoûts que j'ai envie
de faire redécouvrir je les aime
particulièrement dans la palette de
goûts amertume c'est un goût non pas que
je vais me poser mais que je vais
suggérer souvent et finalement ça marche
mais ici toutefois on est
particulièrement gâtés parce que le
magistère qui a pas été sollicités on
n'a pas eu un gros besoin puisqu'ils ont
fait 45 à 50 clients d'envoyer donc on
va pouvoir vraiment proposer des légumes
puis on va se satisfaire de la nature en
fait on vit sous le rythme de la nature
nous sommes les interprètes de
générosité de la nature il ya un lien
c'est mehdi qui les cultivent qui nous
apporte à votre nationalité
et nous on va s'attacher à préserver le
goût originel ne pas trouver ces zones
et surtout pas dessus pas trop de
matière grasse extraire les jus la bonne
température et puisse arranger à mettre
une boisson and harmony noah ce en
harmonie c'est le verre de vin qui va
bien avec à la bonne température c'est
ça notre travail écoutez bravo merci
non c'était bien d'autres merci aucun
prêt la bonne personne et un autre
projet aux légumes aspect renom avec
humeur voire y avait des asperges ici
c'est cette petite serre semi enterrés
on a compris que ici potager la red
alain baraton a fait des recherches et
bien sûr qu'ils avaient exaspérée
il m'a promis tout à l'heure qu'un jour
du potager de la red
nous aurons les asperges
à paris mais j'en suis sûr va y arriver
puisque vous avez connaissance et la
maîtrise avec le temps la patience on
finit toujours par arriver à l'objectif
j'ai envie de vous dire rendez vous pour
les asperges oui mais j'aurai d'autres
rendez-vous avant donc de rigueur
merci non c'est efficace merci beaucoup